revenir sur cette terrible histoire un
adolescent de 15 ans qui s'est suicidé à
Poissy dans les Yvelines début septembre
après plusieurs mois de harcèlement
pourtant ce qui est tombé aujourd'hui
c'est la une du jour puisque ses parents
avaient tout fait pour prévenir le
personnel éducatif professeur proviseur
et même rectrice personne n'a jamais
pris en compte la détresse de
l'adolescent je vais vous lire la lettre
dans laquelle lactrice répond aux
parents c'est un truc de fou elle a été
publié ce week-end Michel Marie va nous
raconter toute l'histoire vous allez
voir on était tous vraiment là je vous
dis ça fait ça fait une polémique
incroyable là c'est pour le coup là je
l'utilise le mot polémique parce que le
mot polémique est utilisé à toutes les
sauces pour n'importe quoi là pour le
coup c'est une vraie vraie polémique et
sachez que personne ne veut parler parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça se passe au plus haute
instance de l'État et c'est vrai que ça
a foutu je peux vous dire voilà ça ça
foutu un coup de pied dans la
fourmilière cette histoire
mais malheureusement
il y a un adolescent qui s'est suicidé
de 15 ans elle avait marre qu'on pouvait
plus son papa doit nous regarder on
pense très très fort à lui à sa maman
également regardez et dans un instant
Michel Marie va nous raconter toute
l'histoire il va vous raconter toute
l'histoire et je vais vous lire la
réponse à au lancement d'alerte de la
famille vous allez voir la réponse du
rectorat c'est un truc de fou parce que
c'est le rectorat qui va les menacer
derrière on va voir ça c'est
complètement faux regardez
début septembre à Poissy Nicolas 15 ans
et retrouvé dans sa chambre pendu à son
lit quelques mois plus tôt ses parents
avaient pourtant signalé ce harcèlement
une deuxième fois auprès du lycée et
déplorer des mesures insuffisantes de la
part de l'établissement
en réponse le rectorat leur a adressé ce
courrier vous avez reproché à un
professeur sa passivité face à un
supposé harcèlement subi par votre
enfant les propos que vous avez tenus et
le comportement que vous avez eu envers
des personnels de l'Éducation nationale
sont inacceptables un nouveau plan de
lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
devrait être dévoilé par le gouvernement
d'ici la fin du mois
alors je vais vous lire l'ensemble de la
lettre dans un instant la réponse du
rectorat juste avant Michel qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé le 15 le 5 septembre le
5 septembre
2023 c'était il y a 13 jours c'était un
mardi Nicolas 15 ans a mis un terme à sa
très courte existence c'est sa maman qui
le retrouve dans sa chambre il s'est
pendu avec un linge de lit
nous sommes donc à Poissy et je pense
que pour comprendre ce terrible drame il
faut revenir un an en arrière c'est à
dire à la rentrée 2022 septembre 2022 ou
cette ce jeune homme ce jeune adolescent
rentre en troisième au lycée
professionnel Adrienne Bolland à Poissy
et assez rapidement je crois que c'est
la date c'était le 30 septembre il est
harcelé
maltraité par deux de ses camarades qui
commencent à avoir des mots sales à son
endroit en lui disant qu'il est nul
qu'il est laid qu'il est moche que
personne ne l'aime
qui insulte également les membres de la
famille de Nicolas en disant ta mère et
ta soeur sont des [__] je vais baiser
ta mère enfin voilà on a ils ont 15 ans
et voilà comment les choses se passent
l'adolescent va encaisser encaisser
encaisser pendant plusieurs mois parce
que en réalité on prend connaissance les
parents prennent connaissance de
l'ampleur du drame au mois de mars et
ils vont très vite intervenir ils ont
été extrêmement réactifs ils ont fait ce
qu'ils pouvaient faire ce qu'il devait
faire d'abord et ce qu'il pouvait faire
en prenant rendez-vous avec le proviseur
avec le directeur de l'établissement
donc du lycée nous sommes au lycée
Adrienne Bolland
clairement on les prend pas au sérieux
on leur dit oui on va on va s'occuper de
ça
bah écoutez je sais pas il y a toujours
un enfant dans dans ces classes qui
subit
qui subit du harcèlement pour ce qui est
pour son physique pour tout quoi c'est à
dire que non non mais on lui en raison
particulière
pour des raisons qui sont complètement
délir il n'y a pas de réalité il y a pas
une bagarre préalable
il est devenu la cible harceleur devient
le bouc émissaire de deux ou trois
harceleurs alors
42 à côté nous Michel et donc au mois de
mars les parents commencent à prendre
les choses en main prennent des
rendez-vous avec les autorités du lycée
les choses n'avancent pas beaucoup on
leur promet de leur donner une réponse
dans les 15 jours les 15 jours passent
ils ont pas de réponse et ils vont faire
un premier courrier que que je tiens à
votre disposition qui est un courrier
extrêmement courtois moi je peux le lire
bien sûr le courrier des parents ce
qu'on va vous raconter le courrier est
extrêmement courtois donc des parents
qui est très courtois et juste avant je
voudrais dire un truc c'est que l'or de
la de de le 30 septembre quand vous
dites voilà que il y a deux élèves il
est prêt à partir par deux élèves
l'établissement déclare qu'ils ne
peuvent rien faire car cela s'est passé
pendant le temps du périscolaire il est
donc selon eux pas de leur
responsabilité ça
pas ça pour moi mais ça c'est
inadmissible c'est pas alors quelqu'un
se fait tuer pendant le périph ah bah
non normalement c'est pas aussi pendant
le périscolaire non non non on a rien à
voir là-dedans non mais ça c'est pour ça
que je me suis permis de le signaler
Michel c'est des c'est cet événement il
va marquer le début quand vous avez dit
de 8 mois de harcèlement c'est ça ouais
donc c'est un truc de fou deux élèves du
lycée donc voilà l'insulte toute la
journée et insulte sa mère sa sœur lui
dit ce qu'il est moche qu'il est nul que
personne ne l'aime donc les parents ils
adressent un premier courrier 18 avril
voilà donc vous allez lire tiens
vous-même parce que
principaux au passage parce que c'est
inadmissible c'est une lettre qu'on fait
les parents et les parents pour le coup
ils ont été incroyables c'est ça qui est
fou mais on a parlé
il a tout fait bien ils ont tout fait
bien voilà alors regarde je vous lis
tout bah oui enfin dans les passages les
plus importants
nous sommes venus vous voir alors ils
donnent la date
pour vous signaler donc que deux
personnes
ont des propos désobligeants à la fois
pendant les cours et lors des temps de
pause à l'endroit de mon de notre fils
nous avons eu connaissance par notre
fils qu'une alors d'une altercation a
failli dégénérer entre les deux
individus le professeur principal a été
aussi tôt mis au courant ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure Cyril mais il nous
a dit qu'il ne pouvait rien faire car
l'altercation s'est déroulée pendant le
temps de pause aussi cela ne concerne
pas l'établissement
donc là on revient sur les insultes ces
deux camarades n'ont pas hésité à dire
ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
dans notre entretien vous
aviez indiqué que vous
mettriez en place une action
au sein de votre établissement
visiblement cette action n'a pas été
prise et au Kian
aucune punition personnalité n'a été à
l'endroit où à l'encontre de ces deux
individus il y a également ces 15 jours
qui ont été largement dépassés vous nous
aviez promis une réponse sous deux
semaines et devant votre immobilisme
celui de votre administration et celui
de vos professeurs donc le 22 mars 2023
donc c'est déjà 6 mois après les
premiers événements nous avons donc
avisé le rectorat par le biais du
Service de lutte contre le harcèlement
du ministère de l'Éducation et de la
situation que subit notre fils et des
conséquences sur son moral sur son état
mental qui se dégrade une main courante
donc c'est en dessous de la plainte a
été déposée au commissariat de police de
Poissy le 12 avril 2023
il est incompréhensible que vous ne
puissiez laisser que vous puissiez
laisser un adolescent subir une telle
violence verbale et psychologique dans
votre établissement sans réagir d'une
quelconque manière aussi allons-nous
déposer plainte et vous considérez comme
responsable si une catastrophe devait
arriver à notre fils termine par
veuillez agréer exactement alors ça
alors il faut savoir que
cinq mois plus de 5 mois après le début
du harcèlement donc le 10 mars le
proviseur du lycée reçoit les parents
et de harceleur sont reçus par le CPE
ce qui se passe rien on est d'accord
il reste en cours tranquille
donc
le 22 mars on est en train de bouche
comme vous dites la famille Nicolas
décide d'informer le service de lutte
contre le harcèlement et déposer une
main courante comme vous venez de le
dire ils écrivent une nouvelle fois chef
de l'établissement et le 4 mai
et c'est là c'est ce qui est tombé
aujourd'hui c'est l'info du jour si vous
nous rejoignez à 20h46 le 4 mai les
parents donc leur fils se fait harceler
depuis 8 mois ils écrivent au rectorat
ils ont été voir le proviseur rien n'a
bougé le fils leur fils est au bout du
rouleau
on est
à quelques mois de du drame
il reçoivent une réponse du rectorat et
là voilà ce que leur dit le rectorat
écoutez bien parce que là c'est une
affaire d'état sachez-le et que il y a
en ce moment une omerta pas possible que
personne n'a voulu venir parler que
c'est un truc de fou et que là ça touche
toutes les institutions et là le
rectorat le fait que on ait pu se
procurer la réponse du rectorat que les
parents de les donner c'est
un drame cette réponse est un drame les
propos que vous avez tenus et le
comportement que vous avez eu envers des
personnels de l'Éducation nationale dont
le professionnalisme et l'intégrité
n'avait pas être remis en cause de la
sorte sont inaccepts sont inacceptables
je les réprouve de la façon la plus vive
selon eux avant cette dernière lettre
les parents de Nicolas ont manqué de
respect au personnel scolaire avant que
je lise la suite de la réponse pourquoi
il dit ça
dans les propos tenus par les parents
mais c'est pas vrai en réalité les
parents ils se plaignent juste de la
situation il demande et qui soit ils se
plaignent que rien ne soit fait oui il
manque juste ce qu'on comprenne en cause
en compte leur et qu'on protège leur
demande on protège leur fils c'est du
corporatif ça alors ce que vous faites
c'est ce qu'on soit à quoi on assiste
c'est du corporatisme il ne se écouter
la suite de la réponse du rectorat c'est
pas la peine de la mettre derrière on va
la lire merci
il convient il convient de vous rappeler
que si votre qualité de parents d'élèves
vous octroie le statut de membre de la
communauté éducative en application des
articles de société d'articles du
communication cette qualité implique
également que vous respectiez l'ensemble
des professeurs personnels de
l'Éducation nationale et l'institution
scolaire conformément à l'article du
même code on a l'impression que ils ont
menacé le proviseur ou pas ou les
professeurs est-ce que c'est le cas
alors que c'est pas le cas mais
absolument pas d'ailleurs je vous ai lu
une partie de l'ail j'ai pas tout lu
c'était tout petit mais c'est absolument
pas le cas cette tête est courtoise ils
ont eu des entretiens courtois ce sont
des gens au dessus de tout soupçons bien
sûr il y a vraiment c'est le
corporatisme une fois de plus de
l'éducation nationale alors
derrière et c'est là ça devient
incroyable un Tor 49 on est en direct si
vous nous rejoignez
la réponse du rectorat donc après
le drame de Poissy enfin avant
d'ailleurs
ils disent par ailleurs conformément à
l'article 226-10 du code pénal la
dénonciation effectuée par tout moyen et
dirigé contre une personne déterminée
d'un fait qui est de nature à entraîner
des sanctions judiciaires
administratives ou disciplinaires et que
l'on sait totalement ou partiellement
inexact lorsqu'elle est adressée soin
d'officier du 6 ou de police
administrative ou judiciaire soit une
autorité ayant le pouvoir d'y donner
suite ou de saisir l'autorité compétente
sur le supérieur hiérarchique ou à
l'employeur de la personne dénoncée puni
de 5 ans d'emprisonnement et de 45000
euros d'avance donc là vous avez compris
qu'il est menace donc en fait là il
menace les parents Gilles directement de
dénonciations calomnieuses là on assiste
à la plaine omerta c'est l'institution
qui veut imposer une charte de silence
attention si vous continuez regardez ce
que vous allez timidation c'est
incroyable que de victimes ils
deviennent
le canon le 4 mai c'est le rectorat qui
fait parce que moi je parle comme ça il
met un coup de pression aux parents d'un
élève qui se fait harceler et qui vient
d'en faire et que vivent en enfer et il
va se passer un drame quelques mois plus
tard donc ça ça c'est une pièce à
conviction incroyable ça c'est c'est ça
ça c'est plus caca blanc c'est une bombe
la suite regardez ce qui leur demande
aussi dans l'intérêt de votre enfant et
par souci d'exemplarité à son égard
regardez comme ils sont vicieux non mais
regardez regardez le vice ça c'est ça ça
c'est du vice ça je suis désolé regardez
comment ils essaient de retourner la
situation et il dit pour voilà par souci
d'exemplarité à l'égard de l'enfant je
vous enjoins d'adopter désormais une
attitude constructive et respectueuse
envers les autres membres de la
communauté éducative et plus largement
tout personnel de l'éducation nationale
qui oeuvre à la prise en charge de votre
fils et agit au mieux à son égard agit
au mieux ils ont rien fait on est
d'accord Michel on est d'accord on
inverse la culpabilité on inverse la
culpabilité c'est pas fini la lettre oui
c'est incroyable donc là là c'est là
c'est une manipulation c'est une
manipulation du rectorat avec l'enfant
qui lit ça
l'éducation code pénale c'est pour leur
faire peur quoi c'est pauvre parents on
veut les terroriser
une amende de 45000 euros bien sûr et 50
prisons à partir de ce moment-là que
Nicolas
a un comportement qui est encore plus
inquiétant son entourage et ses parents
c'est la réponse du rectorat qui fait
qu'il devient encore plus sombre ils ont
une responsabilité directe dans ce qui
va se passer c'est bien de le signaler
ça parce que ça c'est avant ça c'est le
4000 donc ils ont une responsabilité
directe qui est sorti aujourd'hui c'est
une bon je ne responsabilité directe
lorsqu'il va se passer après jacquardoz
on est d'accord oui puisque c'est son
entourage direct décrit que il a changé
il abasculer et que s'il avait eu une
forme de reconnaissance sur le thème on
va s'occuper de toi il y a un problème
on va s'y intéresser qu'il croyait avoir
il croyait avoir parce qu'il avait
espoir dans ce dans ce courrier il avait
été reçu au début
n'aurait-il pas réagi comme ça alors
dans ce moyen harcelé mais je dis que
maintenant à cause de lui ses parents
ses parents exactement
la phrase aussi dans l'intérêt de votre
enfant et par souci d'exemplarité à son
égard je vous enjoins d'adopter
désormais une attitude constructive non
mais non mais vous rendez compte la
manipulation il termine en indiquant que
s'il est pas en adopté pas une attitude
constructive et respectueuse elle serait
contrainte de prendre toutes les mesures
nécessaires je serai contrainte le
cashero de prendre toutes les mesures
nécessaires tantôt bon fonctionnement du
service public de l'éducation nationale
qu'à la protection et la sécurité des
personnels qui concourent vous rendez
compte ou pas c'est une lettre de coup
de pression protège nous cette lettre
elle a particulièrement blessée Nicolas
sachez-le il s'est senti ni cru ni
écouté j'ai senti lâcher par les
institutions par le rectorat par le
lycée d'abord par le rectorat et un
danger pour ça et en septembre Nicolas
il a changé d'établissement scolaire
donc c'est lui qui est harcelé qui a
changé d'établissement il est parti dans
un autre établissement
ça n'a pas suffi puisqu'il s'est pendu
dans sa chambre le 5 septembre dernier
c'est pendu dans sa chambre le 5
septembre dernier et le 4 mai
les parents reçoivent cette lettre qui
reçoivent cette lettre le 4 mai les
parents
trois mois après
Nicolas c'est pendu
il voit que ses parents à ce moment-là
sont malheureusement des pourvu de toute
solution que personne ne les écoute que
personne ne les croit que ses parents en
plus il a du croire Nicolas il se dit je
fais du mal à mes parents exactement
c'est une bombe sachez que personne ne
veut parler c'est catastrophique et ce
qui se passe dans l'éducation nationale
on savait qu'on avait un ministre
complètement absent avant sachez que
Gabriel Attal tu es en train de
travailler justement là dessus et qu'il
va y avoir un grand grand ménage de fait
il a osé dire les mots
ménage il parle pas là mais il va
bientôt parler il a eu des mots très je
peux vous dire il a dit que c'était que
actuellement il y a dans l'éducation
nationale des gens qui tiennent ouais
Jacques on met c'est une affaire qui
fera date ah non parce que tout est
inversé toutes les valeurs sont
inversées ce garçon il apparaît gentil
il y a aucune raison comme tu dis au
départ mais pourquoi il est victime des
autres on y a aucun il y a rien il y a
pas eu d'antécédents donc ce garçon il
est tout gentil il demande pourquoi il
peut pas évoluer avec ses copains il y a
deux harceleurs on les reçoit jamais on
ne leur demande jamais des comptes à ces
deux harceleurs ensuite il y a
l'attitude des parents les parents sont
exemplaires irréprochables la qualité de
leur de leur écrit enfin je veux dire il
y a jamais d'homo un mot plus haut que
l'autre etc et puis ensuite on a le
bouquet final c'est la réponse du
rectorat c'est toute la trois d'heures
de l'administration la bêtise de
l'administration et alors le summum
c'est d'arriver à accuser les parents la
menace faire en sorte la menace et à
faire en sorte que le gamin pour qui on
devrait tout faire pour qu'ils sortent
de cette situation deviennent encore
plus nombreux de cet excusez-moi on a vu
plein de cas de harcèlement scolaire on
a eu plein de drames comment on peut
être aussi excusez-moi aussi débile pour
ne pas répondre et répondre
c'est juste les mecs ils veulent ils
veulent juste ne pas rentrer dans
l'affaire se protéger ils se protège les
uns les autres ouvrir les uns les autres
exactement il y a quelque chose qui est
absolument scandaleux c'est que les
procureurs des lycées
moi les proviseurs des lycées ne veulent
pas signaler les cas de harcèlement
pourquoi bien sûr parce que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui quand il signale au rectorat
ou à l'Académie un cas de harcèlement on
leur dit tais-toi sinon tu vas être mal
noté le recteur ne voulait pas signaler
au ministre les cadeaux harcèlement en
se disant on va dire que dans mon
académie je ne gère pas bien donc il
faut retourner tout le truc avec la
complicité du mini je le dis ça n'engage
que moi du ministre de l'éducation
nationale d'avant sur incitait aussi
bien sûr donc maintenant il faut
retourner le ministre de l'éducation
nationale d'avant il voulait juste pas
avoir problème il est venu il était
trois qui est au club regardez en
revanche la réaction Gabriel Attal
Gabriel qui a eu des mots très dur hein
ce courrier est une honte une honte dès
lundi je réunirai l'ensemble des
rectrice et directeurs
puisque je veux lancer un audit dans
l'ensemble des rectorats sur toutes les
situations de harcèlement qui ont été
signalées jusqu'au rectorat l'année
passée
parce que malgré tout pardon mais la
rectrice à l'époque n'y est plus en
poste aujourd'hui je crois que c'est la
rectrice des Yvelines je pense qu'elle
doit être convoquée je pense qu'il va y
avoir une enquête sur elle parce qu'elle
a été nommée là parce que c'était une
amie de Macron alors qu'elle devait pas
normalement être actrice elle avait pas
les compétences c'est ce qu'on a dit il
y a aussi un scandale peut-être
politique
cette histoire Géraldine et je te le dis
c'est un truc de fou sachez-le donc je
revenais à 20h57 l'histoire de Nicolas
qui est un drame son père je pense à lui
très fort je pense très fort à sa mère
également
j'ai eu car l'olive aussi au téléphone
aujourd'hui merde de Poissy qui lui est
dans un état longtemps il connaissait
très bien les parents Carl lui aussi il
est dépité parce qu'il s'est passé
sachez-le et tout le monde me dit pour
l'instant
nous a demandé c'est la meilleure
personne ne doit parler pour l'instant
c'est Gabriel Attal qui parlera à priori
la semaine prochaine pour annoncer je
vous le dis il y aura un avant un après
pour annoncé des très grandes mesures
par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
j'espère qu'il viendra les annoncer ici
regarde mais sachez que ça va bouger et
que là c'est liste c'est une
déflagration mais malheureusement je
vous le dis parce que tout le monde
s'agite autour mais moi je pensais aux
parents de de Nicolas qui ont tout fait
ils ont tout fait bien et ils se disent
aujourd'hui nous le système nous a tué
bien sûr et on tue et il a tué notre
fils aussi
c'est la même académique Samuel Paty des
annonces à cette époque là il avait été
aussi complètement abandonné donc là
c'est très très grave ce qui s'est passé
sachez Michel ce que vous avez quelque
chose à ajouter non je pense qu'on a à
peu près tout dit il faut effectivement
attendre moi j'ai beaucoup aimé la
réaction de Gabriel Attal
qui pour un ministre de l'éducation
nationale à
porter sa voix et très vite sans dire on
attend les résultats de l'enquête enfin
le bla bla bla habituel il a été il a
été il a clairement dit les choses c'est
une honte et il leur donne un audit donc
c'est bien merci